F of 2 equals eight, g of 2 equals 3, and f plus g of 2 equals 11. Nice
thinking if you got all 3 correct. To find the f of 2, we'll start by plugging
the value of 2 in for X. So we'll have 3 times 2, which equals 6 plus 2, which
equals 8. So when the input of the function x equals 2, the output of the
function is 8. For g of 2 we'll use a similar approach. We'll plug in the value
of 2 in for x, so we'll have g of two equals 2 squared minus 1. 2 squared
equals 4, minus 1 is 3. So, we know that g of 2 is 3. And for this last one it
just means we want to take the value of f of 2 and add it to the value of g of
2. We're wondering what's the sum of the outputs, when both functions are
evaluated at x equals 2? Well, we know f of 2 equals 8 and we know g of 2
equals 3. So we're really just adding these two outputs together to get 11, and
we can also see this on a graph. Here I've graphed f of x and g of x in Desmos.
F of x is this straight orange line and g of x is this curved parabola. Notice
that the f of 2, or the output for the orange function when x equals 2. Is
positive 8 right here. If I zoom out, you can see that more clearly. And notice
that the output for g of x, when x equals 2, is positive 3 here. So, we're just
going to add the output here of 8 to the output here of 3. When we add the two
outputs together, we'll get 11.